pas parler de l'affaire Plaza pas
l'hôtel euh l'animateur qui est accusé
donc le violence conjugale sur plusieurs
de ses anciennes compagnes est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est faux c'est plus
aujourd'hui cette histoire prend encore
un autre tournant puisque toute la
presse c'est emparée du sujet tout le
monde en parle qu'est-ce qu'on ne sait
plus la réaction que Stéphane les
émissions de l'agent immobilier
vont-elles traiter programmées on parle
de vice de l'animateur voilà de de plein
de choses il y a 10 infos qui sont
sortis on va vous les donner et on va
voir si c'est vrai ou si c'est faux avec
Maria Palomba regardez cet extrait
puisque tout le monde en parle
toutes les trois rapporte des faits de
maltraitance humiliation menaces
violences verbale et même physique pour
deux d'entre elles selon l'une de ces
femmes Stéphane Plaza exercerait des
pressions dans le but de faire cohabiter
plusieurs relations en même temps à la
sur avoir eu trois doigts cassés par
l'animateur lors d'une dispute une autre
indique avoir déposé une main courante
en 2022 après des menaces de mort et un
refus de l'animateur de lui rendre les
clés de son domicile enfin la troisième
raconte avoir mis fin à leur relation
après avoir été menacé lors d'un
week-end en amoureux à Vienne en
Autriche alors qu'elle venait de
découvrir qu'il l'a trompait voilà
Vienne et d'ailleurs on a un tweet qui
nous dit que deviennent les valses
deviennent
Myriam
déjà première question qu'est-ce qu'on
reproche à Stéphane Plaza alors vous
l'avez excusez-moi dit dans le résumé
mais effectivement on reproche à
Stéphane Plaza d'avoir
perpétrer des violences contre contre
des femmes de les avoir humiliées et
voir même de les avoir menacé de mort
dans dans l'enquête de Mediapart il y a
trois victimes qui s'expriment et donc
elle décrivent l'anonymat elles ont
gardé
l'anonyme plein de contre lui alors
elles pas porter plainte il y a juste
une main courante qui a été faite par la
c'est rien du tout c'est juste pour
signaler qui a eu un problème donc il y
a pour l'instant il n'y a pas de plainte
et elles expliquent elles n'ont pas
osé porter plainte par peur de la sur
médiatisation de la faire bon c'est un
peu raté Gilles c'est lui qui a porté
plainte exactement
une main courante en octobre 2021 et une
plainte pénale pour harcèlement et
cyber-harcèlement en juin 2023 est-ce
que tu peux appeler l'effet vraiment
parce que dans les détails il y a eu des
choses voilà qui sont passées on enlève
il y a une jeune femme avec il est resté
plusieurs années qui qui explique que
après lui avoir dit qu'il savait qu'il
l'a trompé il aurait eu une altercation
il lui aurait mis le bras au niveau de
la gorge là-dessus pendant l'altercation
elle aurait eu un arrachement ceux et
une luxation des articulations de doigts
enfin bref il y a tout un tas de choses
qui se sont passées donc ça il explique
on a vu aussi les SMS parce qu'il y a
des SMS qui ont été échangés où on voit
aussi la photo de de la jeune femme qui
porte une attelle Stéphane Plata se
serait même vanté sur un tournage de
publicité que il avait luxé la le doigt
de quelqu'un qu'il avait énormément de
force et puis elle dit aussi qu'il y a
eu deux autres faits où il lui aurait
donné un coup de poing en 2018 et il lui
aurait lancé un colis en 2020 alors il a
il a porté plainte pour harcèlement
mais il y a une des jeunes filles je
crois qu'il y avait déjà eu des plaintes
c'est que l'avocate de Stephen c'est des
bruits qui courent aussi il a dit dans
Surat ton âge il y a des sms il y a des
sur un tournage moi aussi j'ai dit sur
un tournage j'ai mis les pains au
chocolat que j'adore les croissants non
mais voilà donc j'ai discuté avec avec
Maître plume et qui m'expliquait bon
elle a pas encore tout vérifié mais
visiblement il y aurait une une des
plaignantes qui auraient déjà des
accusations des plaintes pour
harcèlement trois faits de femmes sur
d'autres personnes exactement donc voilà
donc ça c'est voilà donc ça c'est c'est
quand même un élément important du
dossier et tu nous le diras si ça avance
là-dessus Myriam deuxième question
puisqu'il y a plein de choses qui
sortent sur Stéphane Plaza vous allez
voir il fait la une de tous les journaux
people M6
Vatel déprogrammer les émissions de
Stéphane Plaza alors pour l'instant
c'est des rediffusions qui seront été
qui ont été
trentaine de M6 il faut savoir
qu'actuellement Stéphane Plaza tourne un
téléfilm avec Michel Bernier qui
s'appelle la cavale ils sont dans le sud
de la France il y a un programme qui
doit être diffusé le disque 10 octobre
qui s'appelle Stéphane plateval Plaza le
voyage intimiste avec mon père alors là
pour l'instant m6 se demande si en
fonction de la façon dont on va évoluer
voyage intimiste avec mon père on va
partir avec son père son père
donc
voilà c'est voilà il va notamment parler
de ça de sa mère de sa mère dans ton
et du coup ça c'est censé diffuser le 10
octobre mais là m6 se pose la question
de savoir si voilà donc ça il peut avoir
une déprogrammation de dernière minute
exactement il commence à s'interroger
M6 commence à s'interroger clairement et
d'ailleurs M6 a débuté son enquête
interne avec beaucoup d'auditions et on
a appris que réservoir pro de la société
de production avait aussi diligenté une
enquête interne pour faire toute la
lumière plein de gens seront
auditionnelles ils veulent faire ça
aussi si ils peuvent aller ils veulent
aller assez vite pour pouvoir si c'est
faux disculper Stéphane Plaza pour qu'il
puisse reprendre ses activités
absolument et continuer à diffuser les
émissions et il faut rappeler aussi que
M6 est associé de Stéphane Plaza dans
les agences immobilières c'est le
principal actionnaire
de Stéphane Plaza donc
60 pour M6
Stéphane à moins
M6 c'est quand même un peu la pelouse
odeurs au niveau des agences
immobilières certes mais aussi des des
émissions donc c'est très compliqué
donc là il faut qu'il reprenne les
émissions voilà mais je pense qu'il a un
contrat très longue durée je crois qu'il
a un contrat très très longues
alors que dit Stéphane Plaza en privé
alors c'est là où c'est un peu
difficile à dire parce que alors lui ce
qu'il aurait dit c'est que il en avait
rien à faire que de toute façon il était
intouchable et que ça veut dire qu'il
est sûr de lui ça veut dire que lui il
pense que en fait ce sont juste des
jeunes femmes et conduites qui se sont
liguées contre lui pour lui faire du mal
et voilà donc pour l'instant ça lui
passe ça lui passerait en tout cas
c'est dommage
à cette théorie là on l'entend mais
qu'il en a rien à faire je pense pas
j'en suis même convaincu que non je le
sais oui vous le savez parce que votre
votre compagnon a produit notamment une
de ces pièces de théâtre donc il connaît
bien alors il s'en fiche pas du tout il
est touché c'est sûr mais voilà mais
mais en fait ce que veut dire Myriam je
pense aussi c'est que il il disait ça
dans le dans le sens où il sûr de lui il
sait que voilà pour lui il a rien fait
mal et qu'il est il est assez sûr de son
fait
cette semaine il me disait voilà moi
j'étais bien sûr j'étais touché par tout
ce qu'on disait mais je savais que voilà
j'étais pas dans dans j'étais pas en
tort euh quatrième question
qu'est-ce qui alors parce qu'on voit
tout j'ai même pas envie de poser cette
question il dit parce que ils disent
n'importe quoi non mais c'est pas ça
c'est que dans les dans les journaux là
on voit tout n'importe quoi Stéphane
Plaza et voilà a-t-il un problème avec
le sexe non mais que quand tu sais que
cette connerie non mais c'est vrai pas
avoir un problème avec le sexe que ce
que ce que ces journées et aussi à
raison il faut quand même pas non plus
exagérer c'est que c'est vrai Stéphane
Plaza sur les tournages il est hyper
lourdo c'est vrai qu'il se branche il
fait il prend il branche des femmes
il m'a branché
direct
il ferait des blagues salaces closer dit
que sur le tournage d'une émission qui
s'appelait les experts c'est vous il
aurait même dragué une femme mariée ce
qu'aurait fortement déplu au mari qui
était
il a rien fait de mal c'est quoi ça
a été marié non mais alors
il est à l'écran comme il est dans la
vraie c'est ça il fait quand on le voit
d'ailleurs dans ses émissions exactement
il rigole même une sonnerie il est
complètement il est complètement
hétérosaire des blagues pour rigoler
c'est son personnage et donc ça peut
paraître lourdon ça je veux bien
l'entendre mais de là à ce que on est on
fait la même chose
mais c'est vrai non mais entre nous deux
tu vois c'est ça
je fais juste retranscrire ce que disent
les gens qui travaillent avec lui et
c'est vrai qu'il y a des gens qui
travaillent avec lui et qui disent
qu'effectivement c'est un lourdeau voilà
et que on a même il y a même une
anecdote je crois que c'est dans le
magazine Voici qui raconte que même dans
les toilettes de réserva de de Réservoir
Prod il a été faire l'amour avec des
femmes donc c'est un peu voilà
mais voilà c'est j'avais juste envie de
faire pipi je suis passé là tout le
monde malheureusement voilà je dis bon
excusez-moi s'il vous plaît merci
[Applaudissements]
tu crois Daniel dans les toilettes de
France Télévisions
tu crois pas non mais c'est vrai non
mais ça il y a rien de grave quand il se
passe quelque chose comme ça et que tous
les médias s'acharnent sur ça il y a
toutes les langues qui se déguisement et
qui le détestent ils sont jaloux de lui
et tout bien raconter des anecdotes
voilà que ce
journalment dans les magazines
aujourd'hui qui est invraisemblable
incroyable un vrai semblable il parle de
sexe bien sûr on a des questions donc si
tu veux nous [__] les conducteur vas-y
euh cinquième question là maintenant
aussi c'est un déferlement puisqu'ils
disent aussi maintenant qu'il a alors il
a des problèmes avec ils ont ils ont
tout trouvé il a des problèmes de de
d'alcool aussi alors ça pour le coup il
a il en a parlé lui à plusieurs
il a dit qu'il avait un problème avec
l'alcool ce qu'on peut on parle de
d'alcool mondain vous savez quand on
boit fréquemment dans les soirées etc et
lui-même a dit sur Instagram qu'il était
super content parce que ça faisait plus
de 200 jours à au moment où il a fait ce
message que il avait arrêté l'alcool et
que d'ailleurs il était super content
parce que son corps allait mieux il
était moins ridé il avait moins de cerne
donc lui-même en a parlé de ce problème
d'alcool
alors ici maintenant ils disent Stéphane
pasteur consomme de la drogue point
d'interrogation ils ont tout trouvé ils
l'ont tous dit la drogue il prend de
l'alcool il a des problèmes de sexe de
de de de de je veux pas me fâcher avec
mes concurrents après ils vont dire que
je suis là pour les mais c'est vrai que
voici a dit que Pierre Palm pardon
non mais voilà
mais justement c'est pour ça que c'est
j'ai fait là-dessus c'est parce que dans
Voici il raconte que dans son
appartement voilà il utiliserait de la
drogue et que d'ailleurs il aurait fait
des soirées avec un célèbre humoriste
avec la drogue c'est un cocktail
explosif qui peut lui faire péter les
plombs
c'est pas qui c'est un proche il a dû le
voir une fois il lui a dit c'est faux
alors
désolé c'est faux c'est faux moi j'ai
passé des semaines entières avec
Stéphane je sais très bien il ne prend
pas de drogue l'alcool oui comme plein
de gens et parfois on peut avoir des
moments de vie on a des problèmes avec
l'alcool ça arrive mais Stéphane ne
prend pas de drogue donc ça c'est de la
mais après après les mecs voilà après il
fait ce qu'il veut à la limite non oui
mais autant dire la vérité quoi
Stéphane Plaza a-t-il perdu pied avec la
mort de sa mère alors ça c'est vrai
alors ça sa maman est partie en 2016
d'un concert de sa vie c'est la pire
épreuve de sa vie il en a même perdu la
voix à ce moment-là il a mis très
longtemps avant d'accepter de faire le
deuil donc il en parle énormément et
c'est vrai qu'il était très très proche
de sa mère et que quand et comme il a
fallu en plus l'accompagner jusqu'à sa
mort et qu'en plus il a fallu lui mentir
en lui disant qu'elle allait s'en sortir
c'est quelque chose qui fait beaucoup
culpabiliser ses Stéphane Plaza et qui
l'a mis mal pendant très longtemps et
d'ailleurs sur Instagram tous les ans il
poste un message en l'honneur de sa
maman
voilà alors après d'autres questions
c'est facile de travailler avec Stéphane
[Musique]
jovial voilà de d'amusant etc après
c'est vrai que il se dit qu'il est
parfois incontrôlable et que
effectivement ces blagues un peu un peu
lourdes certains candidats et même des
gens sur le plateau de tournage
qui prennent sa défense dont Laurent
Ruquier alors oui Laurent Ruquier a pris
sa défense il y a tout son entourage qui
le soutient énormément son sa
productrice parce qu'elle Albertini a
démenti aussi fermement les accusations
il y a Karine Lemarchand qui évidemment
sa grande copine qui le soutient
forcément elle est au courant si oui bah
Karine de quoi
Daniel au courant ils sont très près
quand il a des coups de mousse et quand
il a des coups de mousse et chez elle
qui va dans le Sud se reposer enfin
voilà ils sont très très proches
effectivement
quand on a quand il arrive quelque chose
comme ça à ton ami s'il a fait de la
merde on le défend pas à tout prix là
s'il est défendu là c'est parce que il y
a des raisons je pense pas que des
personnes comme Karine Le Marchand ou
Laurent défendent juste comme ça parce
que c'est l'ami mais et qu'en fait
potentiellement c'est vrai c'est faux il
y a beaucoup de choses qui sont fausses
et c'est pour ça qu'ils le défende pas
uniquement parce que c'est c'est un ami
voilà on ne pas toujours ses amis quand
un ami fait de la merde et ben parfois
on ferme sa bouche notamment des
accusations liées à une personne qui
serait manipulateur presque gourou quand
vous lisez les trucs vous avez
l'impression d'un gourou c'est le Love
bombing c'est à dire que il dit aux
femmes vous êtes génial et après il est
détruit voilà ça de la ville de ses
proches moi je sais que je l'ai côtoyé
aussi
encore une fois on sait pas ce qui se
passe en privé mais j'ai jamais vu de sa
part avec d'autres gens ou avec lui de
là non mais comme ça une volonté de
manipuler vous voyez ce que je veux dire
ça mais c'est pas non mais là quand vous
lisez c'est un déferlement c'est un
manipulateur un gourou
est-ce que des poursuites judiciaires
peuvent être possibles
donc là non
mais par contre lui il peut les attaquer
plein dedans
donc c'est là où c'est un peu bizarre
parce qu'on se demande quel est le but
par peur d'être sur médiatisé mais c'est
un peu raté donc ça peut rater donc on
dirait qu'on se demande pourquoi ils
n'ont pas porté plainte vous cette
histoire est-ce que vous pensez que ça
va s'arranger ou pas comme tous à tous
et tout tout fil ça fait l'actu là
maintenant c'est vrai que ça fait la une
de tous les magazines parce que parce
que parce qu'il y avait certainement pas
beaucoup d'actualité à ce moment-là mais
mais bon après voilà il faut laisser
quand même les enquêtes internes se
faire et je crois que c'est très
important aussi de malgré tout d'écouter
des d'écouter ces femmes et de voir
d'ailleurs il y a une enquête
allez merci à tous